Least mean squares
estimation is remarkable
because it has such
a simple answer.
The way to come
up with estimates,
if what you care about is
to keep the mean squared
error small, the way to
come up with estimates
is to just report the
conditional expectation, which
is going to be a number,
once you have obtained
some values of the data.
Or more abstractly,
you can think of it
as a random variable, if you
do not know ahead of time
what data you're
going to obtain.
Because this estimator
is so important,
it is worth writing down
what the performance
of that estimator is.
So suppose that
you have obtained
a particular measurement,
a particular value
of the observation, then
the resulting mean squared
error within that
conditional universe
where you have already
obtained that value,
is just this quantity.
It's the mean square of the
error between the variable
that you're trying to
estimate and your estimate.
And everything gets
computed within
this conditional universe.
Now this is a very
familiar quantity, however.
It's the expected value of
a random variable difference
from its mean, squared.
This is just the
variance, except that
because all quantities
are calculated
in a conditional universe, this
is the conditional variance.
So the conditional variance is
the optimal mean squared error,
the mean squared
error that you obtain
when you use this
particular estimate.
And it's the value that you
would report to your boss
if you were asked how good
is the estimate that you're
giving me.
But suppose that you have not
yet obtained a measurement,
but you're going to
your boss and you're
proposing this particular
estimator as your design.
What are you going to
report to your boss
as the performance
of your design?
Since you have not yet
obtained the value of X,
X is a random
variable, you do not
know what the value of this
conditional expectation
is going to be.
It's a random variable.
But no matter what
it is, this is
going to be the error that
you're going to be obtaining.
And this is the overall value
of the mean squared error.
So this is the
quantity that you would
report to your boss as
your overall mean squared
error, the value that you
report before obtaining
any specific measurement.
Now, what is this quantity?
This quantity is just the
average of this quantity
up here, averaged over all
the possible values of X.
And in our more
abstract notation,
it is just the expectation
of the conditional variance.
The conditional variance, the
abstract conditional variance,
is a random variable that
takes this value whenever
capital X happens to
be equal to little x.
And when we average it over
all possible values of X,
we just have the expectation
of this random variable.
Let me continue now
with a few more comments
on LMS estimation.
First, something that should
be pretty clear at this point
is that LMS estimation is
only relevant to estimation
problems.
This is because in
hypothesis testing problems
we typically care about
the probability of error,
not the mean squared error.
A second important comment
is that in some cases
the LMS estimates and the
MAP estimates turn out
to be the same.
When is that the case?
If the posterior
distribution of Theta
happens to have a single
peak, and it is also
symmetric around
a certain point,
so that the peak also occurs
at that particular point,
then clearly the
peak occurs here.
But the conditional expectation
is also that same point,
because it is the
center of symmetry.
So in those cases, the two types
of estimates, or estimators,
coincide.
When does this happen?
This happens in one particular
important special case.
We have seen that in
linear-normal models
the posterior
distribution is normal.
And so this is one case where
the MAP estimate and the LMS
estimate are going to coincide.